my name is Jessica Stern and I'm the
executive director of outright action
international and in my spare time I
teach a spring course at Columbia's
School of International and public
affairs on LGBTQ rights in law and
public policy around the world and if I
could say one thing about the value of
this course is that it changes people's
lives it makes LGBTQ students feel and
be seen and it makes straight allies
feel more equipped to bring a queer
analysis into whatever work they are
most passionate about and they are most
focused on it actually helps people
govern better so a few years ago I had a
government official from Indonesia and
Indonesia is a really important country
for LGBTQ rights because for the past
few years things have been fighting
downwards and every day she'd show up in
class having done all the homework and
she had more questions than anybody else
and at the end of the class she said
this class helped prepare me to go home
and govern better I'm going to go home
and work on laws and policies to make
sure they are not persecuting LGBTI Q
people and in some cases they're
actually helping them and I can't think
of a better outcome from any class than
to actually have an impact on law and
policy